>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Patrick Anderson: Good
afternoon, I'm Patrick Anderson.
I review fiction for
the Washington Post.
And, I have the pleasure
this afternoon
of introducing our next
speaker Justin Cronin.
I'll try to be brief, because I
suspect most of you are already fans
of his "Passage" trilogy.
But, here are a few basic facts.
Justin was born near Boston.
Attended Harvard in the
Iowa writers workshop.
Then taught writing and literature
at La Salle University
in Philadelphia.
And, then at Rice University
at Houston where he
and his family still live.
In 2001 and 2004 Justin published
two fine novels "Marian O'Neal"
and the "Summer Guest"
that won admiring reviews.
Won some prizes.
And, then quietly expired the
way that most literary novels do.
But, a few years later
Justin was talking
to his eight-year-old daughter.
Who gave him the idea for writing
a very different sort of novel.
I hope he'll tell you the full story
because it's a wonderful story.
But, I'll just say that
his daughter's idea lead
to his great trilogy of
"The Passage", "The Twelve"
and "The City of Mirrors".
It also led to what I will
discretely call seven figure sales
of both his trilogy
and movie rights.
Someone said that this story has
caused countless American novelists
to follow their children around
saying, sweetheart have you thought
up a really good idea for me yet?
But, the truth is that the
vast majority of writers,
if we were given the
best idea in the world.
Would not bring it off with
the incredible imagination
and the literary skill that
Justin brought to his trilogy.
His books may begin as science
fiction but the transcend genre
and are simply great
American novels.
It's a great pleasure to
introduce Justin Cronin.
[ Applause ]
>> Justin Cronin: This is a
very big room with many people.
The first thing I want to say is
that my first two books
did not quietly expire.
They are in print.
They are available in stores.
I get royalty checks, for
like $100 every six months.
Yeah, the story of my daughter
is kind of an interesting one.
And, it's usually a good
place to start because.
Sorry, that was my
Marco Rubio moment.
Because, I'm very lucky.
I was working on another book and
it wasn't going particularly well.
This is in 2005 and my
daughter did indeed come to me
and expressed the fear,
the deep concern.
And, she was eight.
That my books were boring.
And, that's, those were her words.
And, which she got, she had
not read them, she was eight.
But, she had looked at the
covers and read the flaps
and they didn't seem
so promising to her.
So, I said that's fine
what should I write about?
And, she said I should write a story
about a girl who saves the world.
Which, of course, I think she just
pulled it off the top of her head.
I mean it was, it struck me
as a little ambitious too.
Like maybe I should write
something about the girl
who saves Westchester or something.
But, I said great I'll do
that but you have to help me.
And, so we spent 90 days together.
I would meet her after
school, dressed to run.
I would bring her bike.
And, we would spend an hour
every afternoon floating
around the streets of
our Houston neighborhood.
Just kind of spinning out a story.
And, we had two rules.
First rule everything in
it had to be interesting.
Not a bad standard.
That was the first thing
I learned from her.
I kind of never thought
of that actually,
I was sort of a truth
in beauty guy, right?
Interesting.
And, the other was it had to
have a character with red hair.
Because, my daughter
is a ginger, alright.
And, if you've read
the books you know
that there is indeed a
red headed character.
We did this for 90 days I
had no intention, whatsoever,
of turning this into a book.
I was lying to my kid.
We were all just getting in really
good shape and having some fun.
But, after 90 days past and the
bicycle went into the garage.
I decided I would take some notes.
I thought maybe, you know, we've
come up with a lot of stuff here.
Why don't I write it
down maybe for later use?
Because the book as I said, I was
writing, was kind of on oxygen.
And, I looked up a
couple of days later
and I had 30 single
spaced pages of notes.
Like every detail of
a very long novel
and then quick summaries
of books two and three.
It was just an avalanche of stuff.
And, you know, I can't really
account for it accept to say
that my daughter and I we
just had good chemistry.
And, at some level she
silenced my inner critic.
And, I also was, as a teacher
of creative writing one
of my best parlor tricks was just
kind of taking random information
and shaping it into a story.
It was just something I had learned
to do to impress my students.
So, they would know I was in the
front of the room for a reason.
And, so low and behold I
had all this information
but information is not a book.
A book is a story.
And, a story needs a voice.
So, I decided I would sit down
and just write the first chapter
of this book to see
if it had a voice.
If it had an entry point.
If it had a way of being told.
And, it did.
I mean like right away.
And, you know, ten years went by
and 900,000 words later it's done.
So, I gave my daughter a decade
based on this dare proving,
I guess once and for all.
That the, every interesting
thing a man really does he does
to impress a woman.
By the way the little girl is gone,
you know the bicycle became a
used somewhat battered mini cooper
in which she drove
off into her life.
She's a sophomore in college and
she hasn't read the third book.
Because she's all busy
adulting I guess.
What I like to do with
events like this
and any event really, is I don't.
I just freestyle.
I have no canned spiel.
What I like to do is read
a little bit of the book
because it's fun to read.
And, nice to be read to.
It's not a very long excerpt.
But, I think it's an
excerpt that sort
of captures what the book
is like, at some level.
And, then I turn it over to
the room for questions, right?
It's I guess I don't have anything
to tell you that want to tell you.
I want to know what
you're interested in.
So, that sometimes
creates an awkward moment
when I say are there any questions.
And, nobody does anything because
they don't want to be the first.
So, I used to tell the first person.
I used to say to the first person
would get a Christmas card from me.
But, we don't do Christmas
card anymore.
Because nobody does.
We didn't get any last year so.
So, what I can offer you
is my love and admiration.
Alright, so think of a question.
Alright, I'm going
to read a little bit.
Another Marco Rubio moment.
Each of the books as those
of you who have read them,
which I hope is some
of you or many of you.
Or all of you that would be great.
Spend some time in what
I call the here and now.
It's not quite the present, you
know there's some changes made
to the world.
But, I think of it
as the here and now.
In the first book that's the
story of Wolgast and Amy the kind
of father daughter story
where the whole thing began.
Because of course this was made
up by a father and a daughter.
The second book uses,
it's the story of Danny,
and Kittridge and April in the bus.
In this book, I had a
very specific require.
Which was of course I
had to tell this story
of the Oz behind the curtain.
Which is Fanning the first person.
In fact, it, what I decided to do,
was to do the one thing
I actually hadn't done.
And, I mean I felt like
I had used everything
in my toolbox writing
this trilogy but,
I hadn't let a character
truly speak for themselves.
So, what I decided
to do was I was going
to let Fanning tell his own story.
Which, I confess I
enjoyed immensely.
And, when people ask me what
character I feel closest
to who is maybe the most like me.
I'm sorry to say that except
for the whole destroying the world
thing it would have to be this guy.
So, I'm going to just
read a few pages of his,
sort of his opening remarks.
"Behind every great
hatred is a love story.
For I am a man who is
known and tasted love.
I say a man because that
is how I know myself.
Look at me and what do you see?
Do I not take the form of a man?
Do I not feel as you do?
Suffer as you do?
Love as you do?
Mourn as you do?
What is the essence of a
man if not these things?
In life, I was a scientist
called Fanning.
Fanning, Timothy J. holder of the
Eloise Armstrong distinguished chair
in bio-chemical sciences
Columbia University.
I was known and respected.
A figure of my times.
My opinions were sought
on many subjects.
I walked the hallways of my
profession with my head held high.
I was a man of connections.
I shook hands, kissed cheeks,
made friends, took lovers.
Fortune and treasure
flowed my way I supped
and the flower of the modern world.
City apartments, country
houses, sleek automobiles,
good wine all of these
were things I had.
I dined in fine restaurants.
I slept in upscale hotels.
My passport was fat with Visa's.
Thrice I wooed and thrice I wed
and although these unions came
to naught each was, in its final
measure, no matter of regret.
I worked and rested.
Danced and wept.
Hoped and remembered.
Even from time to time prayed.
I lived in sum a life.
Then, in a jungle in Bolivia I died.
You will know me as
Zero such is the name
that history has bestowed upon me.
Zero the destroyer, great
devourer of the world.
That this history shall never
be written is a circumstance
of antilogical debate.
What become of the past when
there is no man to record it?
I died and then was brought to life.
The oldest tale there is.
I arose from the dead
and what did I behold?
I was in a room of the bluest light.
Pure blue, cerulean blue,
the blue the sky would be
if it were married to the sea.
My arms, my legs even
my head were bound.
I was a captive in that place.
Scattered images lit my mind
flashes of light and color
that refused to gather into meaning.
My body was humming.
That is the only word.
I was to learn that
I had just emerged
from the final stages
of my transformation.
I had yet to see my body
of course being inside it.
Tim, can you hear me?
It was a voice coming from
everywhere and nowhere.
Was I dead?
Was this the voice
of God addressing me?
Perhaps the life I had
lived had not been so worthy
and things had gone the other way.
Tim if you can hear me lift a hand.
This is did not seem too much
for God for any God to ask.
That's it now the other one.
Excellent, well done Tim.
You knew this voice
I said to myself.
You are not dead it is the voice
of a human being, like you.
A man who calls you by
name who says, well done.
That's it Tim just breathe.
You're doing fine.
The nature of my situation
was becoming more clear.
I had been ill in some manner.
Perhaps I had suffered seizures.
That would explain the restraints.
I could not yet recall the
circumstances how I had come
to be in this place.
The voice I thought was the key.
If I could identify its
owner all would be revealed.
Tim I'm going to undo
the straps now.
I felt a release of
pressure triggered
by some remote mechanism my
binding surrendered their hold.
Can you sit up Tim?
Can you do that for me?
It was also true that whatever my
ailment was the worst had past.
I did not feel ill.
Quite the contrary.
The humming sensation which
originated in my chest had enlarged
to one orchestral whole body
vibrato as if all the molecules
of my anatomy were
playing a single note.
The sensation was deeply
almost sexually pleasurable.
My loins, the tips of
my toes, even the roots
of my hair never had I
experienced anything so exquisite.
I heard a second voice
deeper than the first.
Dr. Fanning, I'm colonial Sikes.
Sikes, did I know a man named Sikes?
Can you us Dr. Fanning?
Do you know where you are?
A hole had opened inside me.
Not a hole a maul I was hungry.
Deeply, madly hungry.
Mine was the appetite not of a
human being but of an animal.
A hunger of claws and
teeth of burrowing
in of soft flesh beneath the jaws,
hot juices exploding on the palette.
Tim, you got us pretty
worried in here.
Talk to us buddy.
And, just like that the
gates of memory opened.
Releasing a flood.
The rainforest with its steamy air
and dense green canopy
full of hooting animals.
The stickiness of my skin and the
swarm of insects around my face.
The soldiers scanning the trees
with their rifles as we walked.
Their faces streaked
with jungle paint.
The statues manlike figures of
monster's form warning us away,
even as they called us
forward summing us deeper
into the heart of that vial place.
The bats. They would come at
night swarming our encampment bats
by the hundreds.
The thousands, the ten
thousands of flapping multitude.
They blotted out the heavens.
They took the sky by storm.
The gates of hell had opened
and this was its disgorgement.
It's black vomitus.
They seemed not to fly but to
swim moving in organized waves
like a school of air born fish.
They fell upon us all
wings and teeth
and vicious little squeaks of joy.
I remembered the shots the screams.
I was in a place of blue light
and a voice that knew my name.
But, in my mind I was
running for the river.
I saw a woman riding on the
banks her name was Claudia.
She was one of us.
The bats had covered
her like a cloak.
Imagine it, the horror almost
no part of her was visible.
In truth, my first instinct
was to do nothing for her.
I did not possess the
heart of a hero.
Yet, sometimes we discover things
about ourselves we never knew.
I took two great leaps and tackled
her sending the two of us plunging
into the feted jungle water.
I felt the hot stab of the bats
teeth in the flesh of my arms
and neck, the water around
us boiled with blood.
Such was their furry that even
the water did not detour them.
The bats would feed upon
us even as they drowned.
I locked Claudia's neck
in my elbow and dove down,
although I knew this
would come to nothing.
The woman was already dead.
I remembered all of these
things and then one more.
I remembered a man's face.
It hovered above me
framed by jungle sky.
I was in incensing
burning with fever.
The air around me throbbed with
the den of the helicopters blades.
The man was yelling something.
I tried to focus on his mouth.
It was alive.
He was saying, my friend
Jonas Leer was saying.
It was alive.
I lifted my head and looked.
My room was barren like a cell.
On the wide wall, across from me
a dark window showed my reflection
and I saw what I'd become.
I did not rise, I launched.
I rocketed across the room and
hit the window with a thud.
Behind the glass the two
men lurched backward.
Jonas and a second one Sikes.
Their eyes were wide with fear.
I pounded I roared.
I opened my jaws to display my teeth
so they would know the
measure of my rage.
I wanted to kill them.
No, not kill.
Kill is to dull a word
for that which I desired.
I wanted to annihilate them.
I wanted to tear them
limb from limb.
I wanted to crack their bones and
bury my face in the wet remains.
I wanted to reach inside their
chest and yank out their hearts
and devour the bloody meat
as the last stray current
twitch the muscle.
And, I wanted to watch
their faces as they died.
They were yelling screaming.
I was not what they
had bargained for.
The glass was bowing
shuttering under my blows.
A blast of white hot
brightness engulfed the room.
I felt as if I had been
shot by 100 arrows.
I stumbled backward, fell
curling to the floor.
A clattering of gears above and
with a band the bars fell sealing
me away.
Tim I'm sorry this was
never my intention.
Forgive me.
Perhaps Jonas was sorry.
It made no difference.
Even then huddled on
the floor I knew
that their advantage was
temporary it held no weight.
The walls of my prison
could not help
but eventually yield to my power.
I was the dark flower of mankind
ordained since time's beginning
to destroy a world that
had no God to love it."
There you go.
[ Applause ]
What may surprise you is that
I'm a thoroughly nice person.
Like extremely well
balanced I love my children.
I take my son to tennis
lessons, you know.
Just like you.
Alright so, are we are
the question moment?
Are we at the question moment?
Okay, how are we going
to organize this?
People come up to the microphone?
Yes? Is that how that works?
Okay, we have a microphone here
and we have a microphone here?
And, are you a questioner?
>> I am.
>> Justin Cronin: Go for it.
>> I'm a Houstonian as well so.
>> Justin Cronin: Good for you.
>> Right.
>> Justin Cronin: I
prefer the term Hou-stoner.
I've been trying to get that
to catch on and it's really,
doesn't have a lot of traction.
So, if y'all can help me with
that I'd be very, very grateful.
>> I've got a young son.
So, he'll be all into that I'm sure.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah.
>> I'm not real familiar with
your work, but I really definitely
after hearing your
story want to read it.
But, I just have to say that your
ASL interpreter I watched him
throughout you reading that.
And, he was absolutely great.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah, fantastic.
>> I just wanted to.
[ Applause ]
>> You need to travel with him.
Or, he needs to travel with you.
>> Justin Cronin: Right on.
Sir?
>> So, officially I'm
the first question.
So, I guess love and admiration?
>> Justin Cronin: Love and
admiration upon you my friend.
>> So,
>> Justin Cronin: See me after.
Then it all got weird.
>> So, maybe, two questions.
First, in the first book, I loved,
I thought it was very innovative
the story you told the part
in Bolivia via the emails.
And, I was wondering, you
know, what made you do that?
It was, I thought it was
a great way to do it.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah.
I mean. I loved other, I wanted to
bring other forms of presentation
into the book because I
thought it would be interesting.
But, it was also a lot of fun.
And, the emails essentially
are an epistolary it's a one
sided epistolary.
And, I've always like
that form of the novel.
A novel made out of letters.
And, I wanted a lot
of different things.
I have journals, I
have maps at the end
of the trilogy I have
a lot of illustrations.
And, I have the proceedings of an
academic conference, in the future.
And, what that, I mean the message
there of course is that I'm sorry
to report a 1,000 years
into the future,
academic conferences
will still be going on.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody hanging around
the hotel bar.
You know, talking about
who got tenure right?
But, that's part of like
the appetizing surface
that I wanted to create.
You know, a book that kind of just
drew in lots of different elements.
Because it was, it's 900,000 words.
That's the length of about
nine conventional novels.
And, so I was asking my readers,
this was not a one night stand.
I mean this was going steady.
And so, you know, the
book had to kind
of constantly refresh
itself in some manner.
So, that's why I chose
those other devices.
>> Yeah, I thought it was great.
I remember telling my wife.
It's fantastic and she
doesn't read as much,
she's like yeah great shut up.
I bragged about it.
The second thing is in that
sequence you kind of hint that,
that this species has
been there before.
>> Justin Cronin: Right.
>> On, you.
Is there any commentary you
can give on that backstory?
>> Justin Cronin: Nope.
[ Laughter ]
What I will say is this.
Okay, I didn't want these books to
answer absolutely every question.
I think that's bossy.
I think a book needs to
breathe a little bit.
In that it can have
mysteries that go unsolved.
That are places for
the reader, right?
To construct their
own part of the story.
And, that said, not
everything can fit into a story.
Even one as long as 900,000 words.
There are things that don't
quite fit in terms of the logic
of how the story is being told.
And, I hear a lot from readers
about certain parts of the story.
That they would like to know.
And, that are not in the book.
And, so at some point and I can't
say exactly when it's a couple
of books down the road probably.
Because, I want to get out of
Passage world for a little while.
Just to refresh.
But, I'm going to write probably
two books that have to do with some
of the these adjacent stories.
The best example I can give you,
for those of you who know this.
Is the story of the colonel, right?
Who, is remains and entirely
mythological figure throughout
the trilogy.
And, since the great
project of the trilogy is
to show you the reality behind the
legends, myths, even religions.
The colonel's story
needs to be told.
I just never had a way of doing it.
It just never fit, right?
So, I think that answers
your question.
>> Okay so, do I have something to
look forward to in about ten years?
That you're going to
>> Justin Cronin: Ten years!
>> Or whatever.
I.
>> Justin Cronin: In ten
years, I'll be 64 years old.
I can't predict what
will be going on then.
Probably a lot of napping.
[ Laughter ]
>> I was just throwing out a number.
But, is there is a chance you would
tell that backstory because I.
>> Justin Cronin: A chance.
>> Okay.
>> Justin Cronin: I have to move on.
Young lady on the right.
My right your left.
>> Hi, so the two characters
of Carter and Fanning.
At first seem to be almost
juxtaposed the stereotypical good
and evil.
>> Justin Cronin: They're
kind of in those slots.
>> Right, right.
Initially, and then as you tell
the story of Fanning and you sort
of get into his background.
It almost seems to
set up his resolution.
I don't want to give
anything away to people who
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah,
yeah we have got
to be careful with
the spoiler thing.
Right.
>> But, it seems that at the end
both characters you have a type
of forgiveness.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah.
>> And, I was just
wondering if for you
when you're writing the
concept of forgiveness.
Of intentions of actions
and you know,
understanding a person is
important to you as a writer.
Who, you fundamentally
get to play God
and you were a very gracious one.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah.
>> So, I was just wondering
>> Justin Cronin: I
hope God is gracious.
You know, whoever she is.
[ Laughter ]
I reached the point in
my life where I want
to send everybody to
heaven in the end.
You know, and the purpose
of the Fanning narrative.
I'll sort of put this in
the context of the book.
The purpose of the Fanning
narrative is to remind people.
Well, now that sounds very, that
sounds bossy and petti logical, no.
I wanted you to forget what
happened at the end of his life.
I wanted you to hear a story
of a person living his life.
Because, you know what, he was born
and innocent soul just like you.
Just like everybody in the room.
And, you know, I'm not a believer
in that some people
are fated to be evil.
I think everything just comes
from human circumstances.
And, Fanning's circumstance,
let me put it this way.
Only a broken heart could
end the world, you know?
And, that's the story
I wanted to tell.
And, I believe that it's
important that when you write.
If people are going to
care about the outcome.
If it's going to feel like, it
has to feel like the real world.
And, in the real world
nobody is just one thing.
If I had, you know if I got to, if
I was going to define a personality.
I would say it's a collection
mirror contradictions.
Alright, whatever they are.
And, so I think it's really
important to shed some sunlight
on the villain whoever
plays that role in a story.
And, throw some dirt onto the hero.
Otherwise, they just
don't seem real.
>> Yeah.
>> Justin Cronin: All right.
And, so the whole thing
is of no importance.
Right? It's just puppets.
Right, and I didn't want
to write a puppet show.
>> Well, you did a wonderful job.
>> Justin Cronin: Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Justin Cronin: Sir.
>> Yeah. I actually just finished
reading "The City of Mirrors".
I had been waiting for
like years for that book.
And.
>> Justin Cronin: Me too.
>> And, I just want to commend you
on like what an amazing
accomplishment those three books
are together.
And I cannot imagine the
amount of planning and work
that actually went into them.
I'm a writer and editor myself.
And, so when I read books
I really take a lot of time
to analyze how they're written and.
>> Justin Cronin: Look at the wires.
I do the same thing.
I can't read a book without
seeing the wires, you know?
>> Yeah. And, it's fantastic
when you're reading something
as well written as
"The City of Mirrors"
and this last one and the question.
You know, the primary question that
I had and I had so many questions.
But, one of the biggest
questions that I have in terms
of the writing of the book.
Once I had finished it was you have
three humongous set pieces and in
that sort of conclude the entire
>> Justin Cronin: Right.
>> Trilogy.
>> Justin Cronin: You mean
like action set pieces.
>> Yeah. Yes.
Kerrville, the ship and.
>> Justin Cronin: Shh.
Shh. Shh. We all know.
>> Okay.
>> Justin Cronin: So,
large action set pieces.
Yeah.
>> Humungous.
They rival anything
in like "The Lord
of the Rings" trilogy
and I just wanted to.
I wonder if you could
talk about the level.
I just imagine you
like creating maps.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah.
>> And like diagrams and all sorts
of things and just keeping track
of all of the characters.
What there happening when these
like set pieces are going down.
What, how did you do that?
And, how long did it take and.
>> Justin Cronin: It
took a long time.
That's the part of
the writing process
that I definitely like the least.
>> Right.
>> Justin Cronin: Which
is the part that feels
like a question on the LSAT.
>> Right.
>> Justin Cronin: You know, it's
like you've got three canoes
and Barney will go with
Wilma on a Tuesday and.
>> Right.
>> Justin Cronin: These
massive logical problems, right?
And, keeping track of all
this information, you know,
you can have maps and
graphs and so on.
And, I do that sometimes but
for the most part you kind
of have to hold it in your head.
Because, as somebody
just pointed out.
You are the story's local God.
And, as a consequence it's not just
information that you need to manage.
Which is time, space and action.
The old Aristotelian stuff.
You also have to manage the
rhetoric with which this unfolds.
And, that's actually the
hardest thing to do is
to manage this information
with language, right.
In the second book the
section that field which is one
of the opening sections a group
of families are massacred
essentially on a picnic outing.
Right, and it's a lot of characters.
Right, eleven families and
then some other individuals.
And, the one thing I do for action
sequences to which, basically I had.
This is the thing I
had to learn to do.
Like the other sort of, you know,
personal relationships I had done
that in two books so I felt
pretty confident doing that.
But, writing large action set pieces
was something I had never done
and I didn't see that many story
analogs for it in other books.
Like I had invariably been
kind of disappointed by them.
Right, and so I had to learn how
to manage this stuff
and what I did was.
I actually looked at movies as
a way, they do a better job,
in some ways of managing
that information.
Because, what they do is they use
a kind of omniscience to do it.
This is total writer nerd
stuff I apologize, okay right,
but what I'll say is I had
to learn how to do this.
When I wrote the field, I did indeed
draw a big picture and I quickly,
so I knew where everybody
was at the big moment.
And, what the distances were,
how the shadows would
fall and all of that.
So, that when I actually
rendered it on the page.
It made intrinsic sense.
It would take somebody this
many seconds to run here.
This is happening here.
This is happening here
five seconds later.
I mean I really wanted it to work.
And, as a consequence it
was completely observant
of the reality of that moment.
Even though not all of it came up.
Right, so many characters
were kind of unaccounted for,
their specific experience
was not in the story.
But, I needed to know what
it was in order for the part
that I did include to make sense.
Because like I said for better or
worse I was the story's local God.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Justin Cronin: I got to move on.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Justin Cronin: I got just
I think we have ten left.
So, I want to make sure
I get to some more folks.
>> Thank you.
I haven't read "The City of Mirrors"
yet it's in my pile I swear.
I just wanted to ask have
you embellished a little bit
on the story of how the,
story of "The Passage" came
into being with your daughter.
Because, one of the things that
struck me about "The Passage" was
that some of it is so horrifying
and creepy and you know.
Oogy. And, how do you, how does
that come out of an eight-year-old?
>> Justin Cronin: Just don't
call the social workers on me.
Is what I say.
No, here's the thing.
Some of the material
did, I did indeed sort
of ratchet up the adult quality.
You know, people say
like is this a YA novel
and I say I don't know a hooker
shots a John on page nineteen.
Right? So, there are some
things that are pretty grown
up that did kind of
come out in the wash.
That said, when you come up
with a story and just write
down a lot of information.
I mean, that's what I
did with my daughter.
I mean we just said this will
happen, this will happen,
this is logical, this
makes sense and so on.
And, none of that is actually scary.
Right, information is not scary.
Story is.
>> Okay.
>> Justin Cronin: But
information is not.
And so, a lot people say your books
were very frightening did you ever
get scared writing them?
And the answer was no because
there were no surprises.
Right? I was making it up.
If I, I could do whatever
I wanted with it.
So, I didn't have that
sense of suspense.
I was managing it on
behalf of the reader.
Right, now as for some of the
really dark content I'll just say my
daughter is a dark soul.
[ Laughter ]
But, she's an old soul.
That's what you should say.
My son is a completely new soul
brand spanking new he doesn't,
complete innocent.
And, my daughter was just born kind
of like she'd already watched
every episode of Law and Order SVU.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah?
>> Hi, can you hear me.
>> Justin Cronin: I can, yeah.
>> First of all, thank you so
very much for all of your work.
>> Justin Cronin: Oh,
you are very welcome.
Thank you.
>> So, more of a light-hearted
question.
So, your books have been
optioned for a movie.
Yay!
>> Justin Cronin: Not, optioned.
They were purchased.
>> Purchased?
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah, but
this was a long time ago.
This was in like 2007.
>> Yeah.
>> Justin Cronin: When
Fox bought it.
So, people ask about this a lot.
So, your question is what the hell
is going on with the movies right?
>> No, no.
I'm going to just put it out there.
Whatever's going on with it will you
have some creative control and so
that they don't mess it up?
>> Justin Cronin: That's
a good question.
The first thing I'll say is.
You know, I always knew
that turning these books
into movies was sort
of not possible.
Because of theirs when they
take a book and they turn it
into a movie the first thing they do
of course is they start
throwing characters
over the side of the boat.
Right? But, I hadn't written a story
that where you could
actually do that.
In the sense that there aren't that
many minor characters in the story
and I structured the plot with
this sort of Dickensian model
where everything is kind
of connected at all times.
And, if you pulled out Sara
the story would collapse.
Right? You can't just thin the herd.
So, I knew this was sort of
a fool's errand for them.
Never the less I cashed the check.
[ Laughter ]
>> There you go.
>> Justin Cronin: Little
birdies in the nest.
You know, I had to send
my kids to college.
So, now but what I was
secretly hoping and I began
to hope more and more across.
The and by the way if they made it
into a movie I would have no say.
Right, the writers in
Hollywood you get zero.
Okay, like they pretend that you do.
But, you really don't.
Okay, for a number of reasons
that have to do with who's bigger.
I mean it's playground
stuff basically.
But, the writer really has no clout.
I would have been allowed to
go to one red carpet premier.
That was actually in the contract.
Okay. Also, they were
not allowed to kill
or maim any character
I did not kill or maim.
Okay.
>> I want to.
>> Justin Cronin: No
maiming okay fine.
Now, what I was kind of hoping
along the length of this was that,
you know, there is a new
story telling that's going on.
That's excellent as the movies have
become this sort of orgies of CGI
that to be honest bore
you senseless.
Television has gotten great.
Right? Television has gotten great.
Television is sort of
teaching us to participate
in long distance narrative.
Especially, to read long novels that
are doled out to us in chapters.
In the same way that Dicken's
novels were all serialized, right?
So, everybody's sitting
there waiting
for the next chapter
little door or whatever.
So, as a consequence of that I
was looking more and more at.
I was hoping more and
more for television.
It is extremely difficult to
move a project at a studio
from movies to television.
They are kind of different worlds.
Never the less it looks
like we may have done it.
Okay? It looks like
we may have done it.
But, keep your fingers crossed.
And, I'm kind of waiting right now
to hear like if the ink is going
to dry and what the
ink is going to say.
In terms of my involvement it would
be more in television certainly
than it would be in the movies.
Because, movies would be zero.
But, I'm the expert at the story.
I can, you know I know a lot
and television has been
taken over by writers.
Right.
>> Yes.
>> Justin Cronin: It's
been taken over by writers.
I know all these great
writers who are either dabbling
or going just throwing themselves
into the pool of television.
And, that means that
writers are respected.
And, so the fact that I know what
I know would be useful to them.
So, I imagine I would have
more involvement, right.
That said I have no
specific ambitions personally
to work in Hollywood.
I'm a novelist.
I love the job.
I can wear my bathrobe, right.
I just stumble up to my office
every morning with a cup
of coffee and just go to work.
It's works perfect suits me ideally.
>> So, just a follow
up on that then.
Do you have any plans what so
ever to maybe have a cameo?
In them?
>> Justin Cronin: Oh, God no.
>> No? Your personality?
Come on? Okay.
>> Justin Cronin: Shh.
I'm really shy.
Can't you tell?
I'm super shy I get really nervous
in front of groups of people too.
It's really, what could
be more obvious?
I have to move on because we have
just a couple minutes left alright?
>> Thank you so much.
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah?
>> So, I love taking the journey
throughout all of three books
and more so just the
story and the characters.
I love going all the
different places.
From California, to
Iowa, to New York
>> Justin Cronin: I was really into
the whole North American continent.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I just wanted to get a sense
of like did you choose particular
locations for a certain reason?
>> Justin Cronin: Uh, huh.
>> Was there, have you
been to those places?
>> Justin Cronin: Yeah.
I was really, really devoted to an
actual geography in these books.
Some of that was simply because when
you use something, when you have,
when you put some rules
around something.
A lot of the work's
been done for you.
Right? Because, you can't
violate those realities.
I really only made up one place
in the entire books and
that's the homeland.
Which is actually a combination of
two cities I couldn't get one city
to work, exactly the
way that I wanted it to.
So, I had to fudge.
Which bothered me a lot.
Otherwise, I know and have
traveled every mile in the books.
For instance, to write the first
book I traveled from Idyllwild,
California which is the
basis for first colony.
I taught there in the summer
of 1990 at an arts academy.
Right, again a place I know.
I traveled to Telluride,
the way they did it.
I did it the same time
of year, right?
Because, I wanted to know
what the weather was like.
And, how it felt when you come down
of the La Selle mountains and you go
into that broad grassland
like does that feel like?
Right? Memphis for the big scene.
Here the story because there's
the big scene at the zoo for those
of you who know the passage.
So, here's the story.
I moved to Memphis in 1990 to go
teach at Memphis State which has
since renamed it very tonally
as the University of Memphis.
And, we moved in and we
lived right near the park
in which the zoo was located.
And, the first night we were
there the hollower monkey's
in their cages went bananas.
Okay, which it turns out, they
did pretty much every evening
for the eighteen months
that we lived there.
You know, right at sunset whatever
button goes off in the brain
of a hollower monkey boom, right?
But, the first night it
happened my wife who was
at that time not my wife.
But, we were on the way.
She was like oh my god what's that?
Do you hear the monkey's?
And, I looked at her and
I said what monkey's?
Right? And, so for the entire
eighteen months I refused
to hear the monkey's.
But, yeah, every place is something
real something I felt locked into.
I went and I looked at it, you know.
I mean I really wanted to
do that all Texas stuff is
like right down to the mile marker.
Right, right down to
the mile marker.
Yeah, I just really, I felt like
I wanted to capture something real
in the North American continent.
Because, the novels
about the destruction
of the North American continent.
So, I want to use the real one.
I think that's it.
Right? Right?
Terrific. Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
A few quick things.
I'm going to hang around
and sign books.
I'm a real chatty Cathy in the line.
So, if you have other questions
I will gladly answer them.
And, I believe Lauren
Graff is right?
Hang around for Lauren Graff
who is an amazing writer,
great person and I met her today.
Surprisingly tall.
Who knew. Thanks so much.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress visit us at loc.gov.